on a pris la mer où es tu as oui parce
que l'état dit on se fait avoir la
semaine dernière manche à ce bon vieil
impossible de récupérer la le pensait
avoir de commun donc 5 france alors on
s'est dit ce matin on prend l'avis wet
on allège un peu moins mais on fera
plaisir tous oui bonjour madame
monsieur leclerc et l'âne non parce
qu'on me demande si j'ai pour lui faire
la guerre
nous sommes un brin déboussolés mais
toujours la langue bien pendue maria
bodin 87 printemps et son fiston goûtent
aux joies de l'hypermarché et de la
viande sous cellophane et ce à la
modernisation du mauricien s'est dit
malheureux tout est souple a suffi
caution depuis huit ans nous menace
mairie fils écume les salles de
spectacles en province et à paris 900
représentations pour ces deux
personnages issus du monde rural à côté
d'abhisit à la limite de la touraine et
du poitou des gens simples qui fleure
bon la campagne ici leurs femmes sont
partout le campagnard dans les
entendants je les comprenais mais celui
qu'a vécu ça c'est encore plus
impressionnant c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment marre encore ma mère j'ai fait
découvrir au ciel la vue elle avait
l'impression de revenir 30 ans en
arrière qu avec sa mère qui lui parlait
encore va chercher de l'est
dans le fond les quatre mois d'avancé
c'est super c'est super super g mais
gentil l'unité des gens qui achètent
encore de la chicorée
il a raison les messieurs la chaudrée
est un trésor de la santé dans ce procès
par exemple aller pour moi j'étais
ambulanciers il ya de cela presque une
vingtaine d'années maintenant ça nous
rajeunit pas et maria qui habitait cette
maison là qui est maria qu'est parti
maintenant qui s'appelait maria bodin
c'est une vieille dame bien connu dans
la commune pour faire les 400 coups avec
son vélo solex et une fois de plus à
l'arrivée du bourg la de la route dhabi
elle voulait prendre à gauche pour
rentrer chez elle et il ya une bagnole
qui la doublait l'avait promis son
bras-droit de marjah et puis au moment
où elle a coupé pour aller chez elle
il ya eu percussions et moi je suis
arrivé quelques quelques minutes après
j'ai ramassé maria dans mon ambulance et
c'est comme ça que je me suis attaché à
cette petite mamie c'est comme ça que j
rendait visite est à l'hôpital et que et
que le personnage du spectacle est né
voilà et maria est devenu maria bodin
une drôle de mamie avec un sacré
caractère
c'est aussi un personnage attachant
nouve des souvenirs d'enfance de vincent
à la campagne avec sa propre grand-mère
des moments d'intimité qu'il revient
souvent partagé au pays
d'abord c'est une façon de de retrouver
nos racines et puis aussi de revenir
chercher de l'inspiration ici voix et
puis bah parce que nous on aime bien on
aime bien les géants comme marcel les
gens simples qui nous connaissent plus
pour moi je dis qu'ici on ne connaît
pour être le fils à robert est un
comédien
donc c'est la une ça me fait plaisir
cette identité là j'en ai besoin
vraiment moi j'aime bien d'occuper la
cre en mai puis ses cd souvenir de même
bien du goût à quoi quand on voit maria
dos c'est un peu là la grand-mère du
bois quand elle allait chercher des
seaux d'eau puis et puis tant qu'à
traverser la route abadie gmail et les
voitures éducatif a écrasé maligne et
les voitures c'est une belle rencontre
la naïveté le bon sens de la terre et
toute cette modernité et qui se baladent
internet téléphone portable le clonage
et toutes ces choses là
la maria bodin a plein de choses à dire
là dessus l'euro l'euro c'est bien joli
après mon fait l'euro mais c'est pas une
monnaie pour payer voyons c'est comme la
nakba contre la modernisation annoncées
pour la question les profonds suis pas
content mais ça me fait quand même voilà
qu'on dirait mariale christian gaudin un
couple hors du commun que vous croiserez
forcément sur votre route de niort à
bruxelles où porto vecchio ils sont en
tournée jusqu'en décembre 2003
[Musique]